each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
deine from UW here to speak to us about
Sage William is a professor in the math
department professor of number theory
and has written several books on number
theory he's also the founder and a main
developer for the sage software project
thank you all right thank you so today
I'll talk about sage I'm going to
describe briefly the background to sage
kind of where it came from and some of
the advantages and motivation of sage
and then I'll just show you a couple of
examples so that will be my talk first a
quick poll how many of you used
mathematical software like mat lab or
Perry or maple Wow almost every person
in the audience okay so here's a quick
history of sage I personally use
mathematical software a lot and I
started using math software a lot when I
was a PhD student at Berkeley in about
1997 and I contributed a lot to magma
which is a closed source but very very
powerful computer algebra system for
doing kind of cryptography number theory
algebra group theory that sort of thing
it's a lot better than some of the more
famous systems at least for those areas
of mathematics but in 2005 I started a
new project called sage which mainly has
as its goal to be technically a little
basically technically more modern than a
lot of those other systems and it's also
free which is a big advantage the the
funny model is actually very similar to
the funding for magma it's just that
with magma what they do is they charge
they have government grants and they
charge users and with sage we just have
government grants and maybe get some
donations from users but so it's a
similar funding model Magma's been
funded for decades that way with no
trouble and I think sage can be
as well and I think it's unnecessary to
fund or to charge users and so far
that's proven to be the case so that's
one of the kind of fundamental design
constraints and one of the advantages of
being free is we get to we get kind of a
bigger choice of pre-existing libraries
to draw on to choose from in building
Sage we get to choose anything that's
out there that's free and that's quite a
lot of good stuff saij one point over
two released almost things I guess to
this day I think it would be three years
ago maybe maybe yesterday three years
ago but it's basically the three year
anniversary of sage or birthday not
university I didn't marry sage okay
so there's been a bunch of sage days
workshops these are where a lot of sage
development work gets done
there are sage days 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 and then Saturdays 12 which I'm
wearing the t-shirt for the Themis aged
age 12 which was two weeks ago in San
Diego was to fix as many bugs in sage as
we could so about I think 18 of us spent
around the clock a week just fixing bug
after bug after bug after bug
I personally fix I think 25 bucks so it
turns out that if you take the amount
the conference cost the funder of the
conference and / well take the number of
bugs take that divided by the number of
bugs that cost about $60 per bug so it's
pretty efficient for Sage development
like that's how much it cost to fix a
bug also the most productive sage
developers working as hard as they can
for basically full time for about five
days can fix between 20 and 25 bugs so
that's not so many you think that we I
mean we all thought we would fix twice
as many as we did when we got going so
it's surprising how long it takes to fix
a bug yes there are let's see I have a
nice little document about this which I
will just pull up this is kind of silly
but
let me just show you a little thing
that's actually rocketing open report
dot PDF so this is just a little summary
of what happened so those are the bugs
in sage these are the bugs we fixed at
the workshop that we know of so more
precisely there were 621 known defects
in sage when we started and we fixed
over 200 of them so and these are all
listed on a public bug tracker that you
can go to I'll show it to you
so right here this is the sage bug
tracker and here you can list for
example active tickets some of them are
enhancements some of there were bugs etc
and this list 995 these are not all
these are not all defects many of these
things are out a new feature to Sage etc
you can see each of the known bugs and a
lot of the kind of really there are some
bugs which are you know very very fine
corner cases that you know you really
get reported you'd like to fix them but
they're not a big deal and then there
are some that are really a big deal
and of course we aimed at fixing as many
of the big deal bugs as we could
during the sage days so I think the next
sage release Sage 3.3 is going to be
very very good from the point of view of
having less bugs than any other sage so
that's what we did at the last sage days
which was in San Diego and that was
actually fun the entire conference was
funded by the Department of Defense
because they find sage very useful for
cryptography research so they really
want sage to thrive in their funding its
development so we have a lot of
workshops and this really got developer
energy going I think quite a lot of
developer energy got going already at
Sage days one which Kristin was out
which was in San Diego three years ago
and and it's sort of just growing ever
since we also when the first prize that
in some international contests for
software so in the scientific category
sage win first prize and we've got
funding from various organizations for
work on sage for example last summer
Google funded Robert Miller who's
sitting here to work all summer on what
on partition refinement functions so
combinatoric type code sage has a lot of
a really large amount of highly
optimized code for working with graphs
and partitions which Robert wrote over
the course of about two or three years
now this is new code that you often is
not available anywhere else here's what
I view Microsoft's interest in Sage as
I'm definitely I'm going to tell you
what sage isn't in the
I just want to give you a kinetise
overview so I think that my impression
is that Microsoft's interest in Sage is
that one it could be a useful tool to
support research in cryptography and
related areas such as combinatoric graph
theory linear algebra a signal
processing and so on so know maybe
Kristin wants to compute something and
it's difficult to do in other systems
and it could be made easy to do in sage
so she was a sage to do it sage has a
lot of code that's really really useful
for doing cryptography research another
I think reason in which sage isn't or
sages interesting to Microsoft is in
enhancing the viability of Windows as a
platform for doing high performance
computing so I'm aware of an effort by
another part of Microsoft to fund our
development so our being the stats the
very very famous stats package and the
reason being that are currently there's
no 64-bit version of R for Windows it's
kind of a second-class citizen in
Windows
there's 32-bit only it builds with mingw
instead of M SVC etc it's really not
fully supported under Windows and that's
bad from an HPC point of view you know
if you want to sell customers on buying
a big HPC system and installing windows
on it if you know the main software they
use happens to be say R and maybe they
want to do some crypto research that
involves some of sage it's kind of bad
if say Gerard doesn't work on on Windows
or it doesn't work very very well
because the customer might want to have
to use Linux on their cluster which
would be undesirable that you would
restrict their choice so another reason
that I think Microsoft would have an
interest in sage is that it would be
good if sage ran very well on
Microsoft's operating system especially
64-bit sage and as you'll see in a
minute sage itself
Paquette it's kind of like a
distribution of most of the open source
math software out there so if you make
sage run well on a platform you're
making pretty much all the open source
Mouse software out there run well on
that platform so sage includes gap peri
singular maxima etc includes across the
board all the almost all the open source
math software out there and these are
the two reasons that Microsoft is
funding Sage development so that it will
be a better tool for cryptography and
other research and so that sage will be
much more well supported on Windows okay
now I'm just gonna give you a little
glimpse into the sage community and just
emphasize it's a free program I've
mentioned that several times now there's
also a free web application anyone can
go to a certain website say Genbu org
and I'll do that right now and they can
use sage there's also a sage support
mailing list with nine hundred sixty
four members so I'm going to switch to
the machine that's physically located in
here so it should switch over and I'm
running Internet Explorer and let me
sign out of here and I go to this
website sage and beadwork and then I
login I'm using an account I need you
could just click create a new account
and then you'd have your own account but
I'll just log in and then I got a list
of worksheets and I can create a new one
I just made a brand new one right here
actually and then I can do calculations
in Sage so I can do arithmetic two plus
three
what
can also draw plots so plot say sine of
X cubed times cosine of X from 0 to 5
then you get a nice plot so I'm just
showing how sage works and how you can
use it from just some random computer
somewhere by going to this website ok
now I'll switch back to the presentation
yes No
when I went to that website right here
I'll switch back for a second that's
running on Sage envy org which is a
computer in the mathematics department
in fact sage NDI org is running on this
hardware oops I have to so that right
there is that's Internet Explorer
running on this computer right here
accessing a web page which is at
University of Washington the only thing
that I downloaded was the JavaScript
that defines that web page it's just
it's a web app I'm in Ajax web app
here's the computer that it's actually
running on this is a computer that's
sitting in the basement of the
mathematics department and it's this is
the machine that we do most of our sage
development on it's for Sunfire X 44 50
s each with 128 gigabytes of memory and
24 zeon course and then a big disk box
here so this though what I'm showing you
here this is also sage so it looks like
a presentation it's actually sage and
this is running locally on my laptop so
when I do a calculation here this is
happening completely locally just on my
laptop this is not being served over the
web but you can't tell the difference
except that it might be a little faster
or maybe a little slower depending on I
mean that hardware I just showed you is
faster than my laptop so you know if you
type some cut the time to do the actual
CPU bound work is faster if I do it
remotely whereas the time to maybe you
know get the answer to display as faster
if I do it locally so maybe this is a
little snappier than if I do it on the
other one there's a mailing list for
sage called sage support and it has last
time I checked it had 960
for members and I'm pulling it up right
here and now it has whoo wait a minute
did people drop out 955 hmm that's odd
well huh anyways now it has 955 members
maybe several were discovered to be
spammers or something I don't know
here's the sage website so here I can
show you it directly since I have
internet access so I'll just go to stage
Mouse org this is the sage website and
there's a big download link that you can
click on this link gives you the sage
notebook that I just showed you there's
you click on Quick Start it gives you
just a quick summary of what sage is
about and what it can do kind of gives
you a little tour and there's extensive
help if you want to know whether sage
can do something you can just type a
question in here and it does a search of
all the sage documentation the sage
users groups and so on in fact somebody
somebody askin sage to you something
just somebody do it
ant I want to write non commuting
variables well see what comes up so it's
now doing a search Google found nothing
Google found 12 results okay so now
there's something about it I guess the
web found something there's nothing in
any of the sage documentation at least
with non - commuting maybe I should just
write non commuting without the - love
to see it's giving nothing at all
mm-hmm I know that CH can do things
noncommutative let us search for
noncommutative
ah so quaternion algebra so that's an
example matrix basis común quaternion
algebras nice working with matrices over
non commutative rings etc so for example
if we click here on quaternion algebras
we'll get the section of the sage
reference manual about quaternion
algebras then you can see an example of
making a quaternion algebra and then we
could take this paste this example into
sage like a box right here and now we
have a quaternion algebra and see I
times J is K that sort of thing if I
define it this way that I can the
variables are directly defined so you do
I times J plus okay 2 times K etc so
that is the stage website another neat
thing that is on the sage website is a
development map there's acknowledgement
so this lists organizations that have
funded sage you can see there a lot
there's a map which lists the people
involved with sage development which is
getting really really large so that's a
list of people of contributed code
that's got into sage and I think now the
number is well over a hundred so a lot
of different people have contributed in
fact one of the one of the motivations
for me when I started sage was a
conversation I had with a graduate
student at University of Texas at Austin
where he asked if I come up with a nice
algorithm and implement it what do i
implement it in if I implement it in
magma than the people in Uruguay where
I'm from are not going to be able to use
it because magma cost five hundred fifty
dollars at the third-world discount
which is a six month salary there or
something if I implement it in Perry
we'll only the Perry people like what
system should i implement like Odin and
sage doesn't answer that question and a
lot of people are agreeing with that
answer as you can see by the list of
people developing code there are a lot
of people here I've never met who have
her actively including code in sage
there's for example like a week or two
ago there was some random guy from
France who I've never met who popped up
and started implementing very fast code
for computing discrete logs and generic
groups I mean just start implementing
the standard algorithms and doing a very
good job at it and you know that's
really good just start pops up appears
you post the code we referee it I can
actually probably find the code right
here so I think he implemented for
example it's not the it's in small
groups so Clark Hellman somewhat it is
he's not implementing index calculus
attacks on discrete logs but so it's
this guy wild CH a PU y so he just
popped up posted this code here it is
and it's nice little implementation this
is just one of several things he's
posting and what happened was he posted
the code he described it on the
developer mailing list then he posted
the code then I asked him to you know
explain is it Foster and here's doing
some simple discrete log in the finite
field f15 and sage three to three there
one of the I guess the latest release
versions of sage and that one
calculation takes 276 seconds and now
after applying his patch it takes point
1 4 seconds so that's a lot better so
it's really nice that people just notice
these sorts of things and just start
speeding them up left and right
I don't think it was using Pollock
helmet at all it was using I think was
using baby step giant stumpy yeah so I
mean we have some very generic code but
first it was probably making doing a for
loop and then after that somebody
implemented baby step giant step and
then after that somebody comes along and
does this and I'm sure he's doing this
because for his research this is very
important that this be fast yes
definitely so one thing that we do is
make sure people copy write their code
so at least they're the person that's at
fault and they have to release it to us
under a license that allows us to
include it in Sage so that could be GPL
v2 plus that could be a BSD license and
it could be the Micra the most
permissive microsoft shared source
license which is GPL v2 plus compatible
so that would be a possibility as well
nobody's contributed code yet under that
but my understanding is it's possible
for you to contribute code under like
one of Microsoft's licenses and there is
one that would work so that's one thing
we do the second thing is every single
line of code that gets into sage is peer
reviewed and that helps a lot I think so
for example this particular patch I
reviewed it and if you look let's see
John Komodo I guess also reviewed it and
he wrote all this stuff about what what
the heck is going on and then looks like
Michael pointed out that I'd already
reviewed it positively so but John
Cremona has a pretty famous number
theorist they he's the editor the chief
editor of the London math society the
Journal of London math society etc so
he's a pretty serious guy he's also a
very very involved sage developer and
hear it very regularly referees patches
for this age group so you can see that
here and now it got merged into Sage so
so it just gives you a glimpse into how
sage development works lots of people
all over the world do this but it's
totally possible that somebody could
sneak some patented code in we would
know exactly who did it we would be able
to remove it if somebody complained but
it's
possible it could happen we don't have
lawyers sort of you know carefully
looking over stuff like you guys do but
at least we would know how they could
got there and we could get rid of it yes
look would you suspect that your
lipstick or the dll building it directly
this dealer will delete the file if is
willing directly have to relink
all code we get comes in a source code
there's no and it's sort of like this
code right here literally modifies this
is a patch that modifies our core
library so when we get code submissions
for their people there they're modifying
how sage is written itself so I think
that answers your question it would be
difficult for example if it turned out
that this algorithm were patented and we
had to remove it or we had to get
permission from the patent owner or
whatever it would be difficult because
we'd have to you know revert the patch
which would make everything slow again
maybe some other patches other people
would build on top of it it could be
painful yes it hasn't happened yet to us
but if it does I think we'll know
exactly where it came from and we'll
listen to hovers complaining and then
we'll fix it that's the plan yes yeah we
make zero money all its ages there's no
company I don't wanna make that clear
there's no company at all the only all
money that we get for sage goes into
account at University of Washington if
any individual gives money its
tax deductible contribution it's all and
not for profit type or not yeah not for
profit I think so we tend you know if
you want fifty percent of our money that
we make off of sage your help you're
welcome to it because it's 50 percent of
zero all right here's some advantages of
sage over mathematica matlab maple i
mean there's certainly many
disadvantages and disadvantages to sage
as compared to not lab and Mathematica
and so on but one advantage to sage is
that its core language the language used
for interacting with sage is Python
which is a general-purpose language it's
I think it's it's easily one of the
world's top 10 most popular languages
there's definitely some strong interest
in Python at Microsoft for example
there's the ironpython project which is
an implementation of Python on top of
the dotnet framework so I think Jim
Hugin or something it's the guy who
works here who works on ironpython and
it will definitely be worth thinking
about as sage gets better and better
support under ms VC and under Windows it
will be interesting to think about how
it can work better with ironpython we'll
see how that goes another advantage of
sage is instead of using a custom
language like Matt labs very
mathematically oriented language or you
know maples very odd and mathematically
oriented language it's just a normal
general-purpose language and pythons a
pretty good language at that it's nice
to use its friendly people pick it up
really quickly in practice the second a
second big advantage of sage is that
it's really really easy to write
compiled code in sage that's just as
fast as custom C code and that's not
easy to do an at lab magma or maple but
it is easy to do in sage and I'll show
you some examples of that that's a huge
huge advantage of sage people regularly
post saying why doesn't my do something
like that why doesn't maple do this and
I mean it's really something that kind
of well partly comes for free and Python
it's it's a pretty neat technology that
allows us to do this called scythe on
and I'll show you an example of that in
a minute there's a lot of cool stuff
that's just included in sage or
available to sage because we use a
general-purpose language because we use
Python and there Python has you know
millions of users around the world so it
has a lot more users than these other
systems and there's a lot of code that's
a Priory completely unrelated to
mathematics that you can just use from
sage for example so you want to write a
web server in sage well it's you know a
few lines of code because there already
exists a library called twisted that
provides a web server let's say you want
to write a command email that I notice
with you as spam lover stream but
there's a command in sage email which
will send an email message this doesn't
require that you have any mail server
setup anywhere in fact sage contains a
very serious implementation of a mail
server itself sage is a mail server
because the twisted library which is
included in Sage is a mail server so for
example good thing this isn't tested or
every time you test sage you would send
an email but
if I do this you know you can have some
calculation you're running you wanted to
email it yourself
you'll email to yourself to tell you
that the calculations done it's just a
command and sage to do that and in fact
immediately returns it starts a child
process now process sits there and it
sends an email when it's capable of
connecting to the mail server so if I
were to go and check my email I'd find
that there's a message there saying the
calculation is finished I guess I can do
that
hopefully I don't have any embarrassing
emails we'll soon find out so there it
is the calculation is finished so it's
nice that you can email yourself like
that that's the sort of thing that you
could accomplish that in some of the
other mas but it wouldn't be nearly as
as nice I mean if you wanted to do it in
one of the other systems you'd have to
have some other program like mail
installed on your machine and have to go
through that whereas here it's a command
that's built in and will work on any
copy of sage anywhere just for example
there's but there's a ton of stuff like
this where that's that was left over
from I'm gonna refresh this that's left
over from this example right here so
this is Python the very first example in
the Python tutorial is right here and in
the Python tutorial most of the examples
are taken from Monty Python's Flying
Circus Python is named after that show
rather than the snake case you're
curious so here's some just I'm just
going to show you a bunch of examples of
sage now the examples were ranged from a
bunch of calculus examples to some
examples using sight line to speed up
some real-world code to some number
three examples and plotting 2d and 3d
plotting examples okay so here's an
example where I create two symbolic
variables and now I can type in
expressions and they involve these
symbolic variables so like X to the
power of Y of Pi square root of two
they're all exact objects it's very has
a very similar field of maple or
Mathematica or maxima by default you see
the output as just a linear line but if
you type
something you'll see it nicely typeset
and it's actually very nicely typeset
here let me zoom in on that for a second
actually I can probably zoom with
although the resolutions low but yeah I
think I'll zoom in just emphasize that
this is not an image it's actually
typeset mathematics
I'm gonna zoom in by increasing the font
size of my browser so you see that it
actually got bigger each of those
characters are individual characters as
you can see by highlighting them if you
double click you see the law tech that
defines it what I have here is J's math
yes math is a JavaScript implementation
of text layout engine so this guy david
Carboni sat down with the tech book and
he implemented text algorithm
line-by-line in javascript and you can
look it's a few thousand lines of
JavaScript but it's pretty cool because
it's nicely integrated into the sage
notebook and what it gives you is that
you can type in essentially any tech
expression or any sage expression sage
expressions know how to tech themselves
and you'll get beautifully typeset
exactly like you want because you like
tech display so that's what this is I
mean I assume you like tech here's
another example where just a little more
complicated expanding out a cubed here's
an example of solving an equation so
this is a cubic equation so you can
write down an exact solution you can you
know of course change the form so maybe
I want it to be 17 time how about square
root of 17 times ax plus B what happens
here secretly behind the scenes
currently is that this equation gets
converted into equation in maxima maxima
solves it then we parse the result and
that's what's here it's probably the
case that maxima will not be used to do
all these sorts of solve operations in
the long run i think that will last for
a certain amount of time we're currently
currently a lot of the symbolic just the
pure symbolic manipulation stuff the
very calculus oriented stuff is
implemented using maxima but we've been
doing a lot of work to move away from
that we have a native C++ library
you called pine AK which if you make
your variables and just give this option
new system bollocks equals one then you
get these pine act variables which they
work almost the same as the current
symbolic variables but manipulation is
way faster for example if I expand out a
plus or a plus B plus C to the power of
say 20 using pine AK it takes that long
and I think Maxima will take longer so
if I do exactly the same thing now but
using that's about it well so this was
really the first one was really point oh
one because it didn't use any everything
happened at the CPU and the other is
0.07 so you can see there's a definitely
a difference in speed and the speed
difference will become much bigger if
you do much larger things our interface
to maximum is pretty optimized but we
can get a lot more out of something
that's native C++ another nice thing
about the the new native C++ stuff or
that we have is that you can do symbolic
manipulation over finite fields and
other funny base rings which is pretty
amusing
all right here's an example of a huge
integer determinant so I'm making a
random 200 by 200 matrix every single
entry has 128 bits so just to show you
what the entries of the matrix look like
here's the top left entry so each number
in the matrix is about that big so the
big 200 by turner matrix each entry is
about that big and I compute the
determinant which is a very large number
and you see it took three and a half
seconds less than three and half seconds
here's the actual determinant of that
matrix it's really really big saij is
very very good at computing determinants
of matrices with large numbers and this
example illustrates making a random
matrix and then how you compute the
determinant you call a method
determinant on the object that's the
matrix if you want to see what other
things you can do with the matrix if you
do a dot and it hit the tab key so let's
see how shall I do this I guess if you
you prepare like you're but ready to
call it you don't know what you want to
do so you're like I want to do a dot
something I don't know
so you just hit the tab key and it will
show you all of your options it's like
you're playing a game it shows you all
the directions you can go in so those
are all the things you could do with the
matrix you could you can compute the
determinant you could differentiate all
the entries just get zero here ask if
it's a square matrix compute the left
kernel of the matrix compute eigen
vectors and so on do triple L reduce the
matrix triple L reduce the lattice with
a given gram matrix etc when the bkz
algorithm so you get a big list of
possibilities then if you decide oh I
wanted to determine it then if you're
about to call it and you hit the tab key
again it'll tell you about the function
you're about to call so here you find
out that this will call the determinate
function there's a couple of different
algorithms that you can use for example
ntl has a pretty good implementation for
a certain range of inputs but you can
also use a chaotic algorithm where you
can use Lin box and so on and then if
you look at almost any function in Sage
well actually 65% of the functions in
Sage you will find lots of examples like
this which illustrate usage of the
function and the examples are
automatically tested on a regular basis
before we make a sage release we test
every single of these 80,000 inputs on
about I think 20 different operating
system hardware combinations so for
example on one of those machines that I
showed you before when I showed you that
big rack of computers one of them was
running VMware server which has 12
different Linux distributions installed
into it so we just build sage and all of
them from scratch run the full test
suite and we do that before we release
any copy of sage and then we also have
some other hardware in other places for
example we have a build form at the DoD
that allows us to build sage on all the
machines that are interest to them like
Itanium linux all these sort of exotic
machines before we release sage so again
so there's the determinant of this
matrix and it's a pretty big number
takes about three seconds here's an
example of how to do the same
calculation using maple and the nice
thing is you can call maple directly
from Sage this is a kind of unique
functionality that sage has that is
different than what you get in a lot of
other systems you can call you can like
the command maple of a right there that
takes the matrix a that we have and
converts it into a maple matrix and it
gives us back B B is a reference to a
matrix in a running session of maple
there's one session of maple that got
started running it's sitting there and
inside of that session there's now a
matrix B that is equal to our matrix a
and then by calling determinate which is
a maple function it computes the
determinant of that matrix and in maple
12 there's some much faster determinant
code than in maple 11 or earlier which
would have taken hours for this and
it'll do the determinant quite quickly
yes yes you'll see at runtime a message
that you should install maple and it'll
tell you where to get maple from like
your the maple website in case you've
never heard of maple or something yeah
in fact how about if we switch over to
remember I was running this on this
public server that anybody can log into
well I don't want to get in trouble so
maple better not work here right because
if it does maple is going to sue me for
violating my license agreement so here's
what you get if you try to a maple on a
machine that doesn't have maple it says
unable to start maple it gives kind of a
little teeny piece of the trace back and
if you click here to the left it gives
you a lot more and then it tells you
gives you some hints about how to set up
maple on your computer and and so on it
tells you where to buy maple okay so
that's what happens and it happens at
runtime so you'd have to worry about
there's no compile time linking to maple
which is a serious worry I mean how do
we talk to maple without actually
linking it in somehow but we use a
pseudo TTY so you can talk to Mable yes
probably
complicated programs yes you never know
whether you gonna get there give me
money message at midnight fortunately so
I showed you those 150 stage developers
and there's some there's many thousands
of stage users most of them use sage
because they don't have maple or
Mathematica or these other systems and
or they don't want to use them so the
and it could have I mean a prayer you
have no idea if you have it if you're
not a sage developer the direction in
which sage development has gone but
here's the direction as much as possible
well actually I would say 100 percent if
you call a sage command and it doesn't
explicitly say right in the name of the
command maple or algorithm equals maple
as a non-default
option it's not going to use maple or
Mathematica or magma or any of the other
systems there's maybe like three
exceptions to that in the whole sage
library so as it turns out that's just
not going to happen to you unless you
explicitly wrote code that explicitly
calls maple it's not gonna be calling
maple but a prairie you could I mean you
could have imagined maybe sage is just
this you know big system that assumes
that you have maple in Mathematica and
actually uses it all over the place to
implement stuff that's not how it's
turned out to be though really a lot of
people are using sage so they don't have
to use maple at all it's just that you
know if you're working on sage even want
to compare the speeds of answers or
you're curious did we get the right
answer do we get the same answer at
least as maple right there I can check
to see whether the two determinants are
the same the algorithms actually are
totally different between maple and sage
for computing not determinate I asked a
maple developer what was going on he
said it's using a Chinese remainder
theorem algorithm so it's continuing the
determinant mod lots of primes using the
Chinese remainder theorem and giving the
answer sage is using a different answer
or a different algorithm and it's nice
that we get the same answer so was there
another question
nope that was completely nervous age
code that was written by David Cole and
other people have worked on it too yep
unless it's really really obvious that
it is calling magma it's not calling
magma or so here's the thing say the
stuff that sage calls by default to get
the work done is all included in sage
it's sage calls Perry and GAAP and
singular it calls these systems all over
the place like if you if you let's say
let's say you want to so you want to
make a you want to make a multivariate
polynomial over
you want to try say the fate min
benchmark which is to raise a certain
multivariate polynomial to a big power
actually it's a little different though
I think it's oh you're sure what it is
but here's a benchmark so that's not
easy magma its I think that's actually
the actual benchmarks 20 so so it's
computed the product of two multivariate
polynomials the output has to 16,000
characters have you printed out you can
see it's very very fast behind the
scenes what this did was it used
singular I used a lossy library
interface to singular that Martin L
Breck one of the sage developers wrote
singular is included in Sage so there's
no requirement you have singular on your
system anywhere just when you get this
age distribution it gives you everything
that it uses by default so you don't
have to worry about any of this other
stuff it's just here as an extra feature
just to emphasize sort of the use of
ability of this feature here's a quote
from IRC last night they need to shrink
that actually yeah it's a little hard to
see so this was some guy and he wrote I
can show people at work tomorrow that
they don't have to abandon MATLAB if
they switch to Sage he was talking about
using sage and the interfaces to MATLAB
and other systems and then he's
wondering about the sort of conversions
you can do between sage and these other
systems so I have no idea where this guy
works I don't know what country lives in
he is very excited about sage once his
co-workers at work to use it and they
have a lot of MATLAB code and you know
instead of his cell being hey guys we
have to switch from MATLAB to sage it's
hey let's use sage to in addition to
MATLAB because sage has some you know
nice cool features that MATLAB doesn't
have but sure let's continues email that
we have licenses that labs a really
powerful wonderful system and we can do
stuff in sage and not lab at the same
time okay any other questions okay
here's another example of I'm gonna show
you some plotting examples basically at
this point I'll show you some plotting
examples some number three examples and
then my talk will be over so here's an
example of making a callable symbolic
expression so a sine of 3x times X plus
log X plus 1 over X plus 1 squared and
there you can see it and you can do lots
of things with this like you can
integrate it f dot integrate there's the
symbolic integral you can plot it and
there's what the plot looks like the
plot command has a calling like the
options that you can give it what
they're named how they work are very
similar to Mathematica
it's like thickness everything's almost
the same as Mathematica except use lower
case instead of upper case so it's lower
case with underscores that's just the
convention in Python in Mathematica it's
camel case so you just change all that
there's also a MATLAB so if you like
MATLAB supporting instead of mathematic
as plotting and for numerical for
visualizing data matlab's plotting
syntax is actually in many ways a lot
better than Mathematica swear as we're
messing around mathematical functions
like in a calculus class mouth Medicus
notation syntax and kind of design is I
think personally better so here's an
example where I plot the same function
but instead if I do import pylab that
pylab thing I just it's some Python
thing if I do import pylab as P then I
get this object P that has a whole bunch
of functions I can do P tab to see what
they are and it gives you literally
everything that you'll see in that lab
for 2d plotting with the same inputs
compatibility layer almost so for
example the plot command if you do that
you can see how it works and it's just
like MATLAB you you give the x and y
values you want to plot and it plots
them it has all these little like line
Styles there just like the MATLAB line
styles and so on so you set up a plot by
just calling plot multiple times saying
you want axes in this point saying you
want to legend deciding all these things
using all these options and this guy
john hunter for python he went through
and implemented just everything exactly
like in matlab for 2d plotting and
that's what you're looking at here maybe
not exactly like it but it it's very
very similar
oops and here it is so this looks just
like what you'd see coming out of matlab
and it's the same plot here's another
cool thing in sage you can do whoops oh
I think the X is all messed up let me
make sure ah there it is okay
so if I call fast float then I get a
version of this function such that when
you call it it's really ridiculously
fast it only takes 518 nanoseconds to
call it with a given floating point
input so it's really really fast it's
actually way faster than just defining a
function of Python and calling that
function yes
drew imagine a low in 500 nanoseconds
yep all the interpreter here in fact it
does the entire thing and that amount of
time and this guy Robert Bradshaw is one
of my grad students at UW he wrote
something which converts an arbitrary
symbolic expression into this call stack
and it's very very tightly coded it's
it's a compile I mean the actual
implementations compiled it's written in
scythe on and but but this is all at
runtime this is done at runtime and it
gives you back something that you can
then call and this was really important
because we're we were doing things like
contour plots of functions 3d plots like
3d sort a give a function you want a
plot of a a function you have to
evaluate on a mesh and it was
ridiculously slow to in fact literally
every time it would evaluate one of
these symbolic functions I would cloth
two Maxima maximum I plug numbers and
simplify the result then we would parse
that so you know you tried to plot a
little function it would spend like 30
seconds just trying to evaluate the
function on a big mesh so you'd end up
making all the defaults so that it would
only you know evaluate 15 points in each
direction or something ridiculous so
Robert thought this was completely
stupid so he just spent a weekend and he
wrote this fast flip thing it works on
not just single variable objects you can
also you can make up a function of many
variables and it works just as well X or
X cubed times sine of x squared plus
cosine of X times y is 1 over X plus y
plus C so it's three variables now I can
make a fast flow thing on those three
variables and I can call it and we'll
see how faster does that so seven or 15
nanoseconds to evaluate that expression
on these three input variables so it's
very very fast you remember the other
one is 500 nanoseconds and this is pure
Python so if you do the same thing in
Python exactly the same expression as I
had before it's 10 over 10 times longer
so we're really beating what you get
from the Python interpreter
so yeah so you just wrote this and it's
very very nice there's an engineer at
Newton labs Karl witty it's a place that
has computer vision and Renton and he's
been working on making a much more
sophisticated version of this fast float
that doesn't require the input to be a
float so that's going to be pretty cool
so it'll be something like this but for
finite fields and all kinds of other
things you can imagine this will be
really useful for maybe for numerating
points on varieties over finite fields
that sort of thing you know that's when
I was cool little gems that are in Sage
I think I'll just skip this this is just
doing integration and sage and maple and
comparing the answers here's a cool
example so this shows how you can use
pylab
just like you'd use Mathematica or sorry
not lab for loading images and
manipulating them and it's really cool
if you do em read you can read in an
image so here's a picture of Seattle and
what it does is this is the
red green and blue channels it gives you
a three-dimensional array of basically
it's like three arrays one for red one
for blue and one for green but it's a
single object a that's a three
dimensional array I'll show you just a
little bit of it so you can do like it's
made printout a lot of stuff yeah so
that's the upper-left pixel it has these
red green and blue values and here the
second thing I did was I took that image
and I took just the blue Channel and
that's what the right thing is so you
can plot like that you can also have fun
you could for example if you take one
minus the matrix then plot it and it
inverts it so you can do a little image
manipulation mathematically like that
you can also I don't know what this
means cuz I'm not quite sure it
inverting at three you know a three
dimensional array means but I've
inverted the picture I'm not actually
don't know what that means I don't know
if it inverts each of the three
individual matrices that give the red
green and blue channels I just don't
know I probably should figure that out
but it looks amusing okay here's an
example of something called interact you
can just play if you put that little
thing that decorator as it's called at
interact before any function definition
then the function because interactive
and you get interactive control over the
inputs to the function notice that this
function has two inputs and integer I
which is going to be the number of
eigenvalues used to compress an image
and a boolean flag whether to display
the axes on the outside and those inputs
get converted into controls there's a
slider for I and a checkbox for whether
or not to display axes if I click the
checkbox it'll redraw it it'll rerun the
function but with the oxys not displayed
if I drag the slider it will change how
many eigenvalues are used for
compression so there it uses seven and
hence the image that's really washed out
whereas if I use say I don't know
thirty-eight then the compressed image
looks reasonably good though of course
the
it's better and if I use more than it's
almost indistinguishable but it's nice
to be able to you know play around with
this in your web browser like this this
is very very similar to mathematic as
manipulate and except there's doesn't
work in a web browser and is a little
bit more powerful in some ways but this
is quite powerful we have a lot of
different controls like if you wanted to
choose a color for some reason you can
it'll give you a color selector so when
you click there than it would like that
variable gets set equal to the color you
click on etc so there's lots of
different things like that
and there's little matrices if you
wanted to have a matrix you could do n
equals say a matrix
maybe integers and make a 2x2 matrix and
there it is and then you could fill it
in and when you change the values then
the function gets rerun but with M set
to those values so it's pretty cool it's
a really really useful idea I think it's
I would say it's a great idea in
Mathematica but it's not actually
Mathematica I just copied it from what
had been done by other people you can
already see this in like some old
there's certainly some old UNIX tools
for making gooeys that do similar things
and in the Python world in theit has a
whole sort of their core technology
something called the inside traits
library and it does essentially this but
it's just more complicated to use so
it's it's a pretty cool idea that it
just make functions in your octave like
thought and now here's some 3d plots so
if we make up a function like that say
sine X minus cosine sorry sine of X Y
minus cosine of X maybe let's make it
more complicated maybe x2 power of 5 and
what we get is a 3d plot and it's you
can zoom into it you can zoom out you
can rotate it around and so on the way
it works is that there's a Java applet
that gets embedded in the web page that
does 2d plot or 3d plotting but only use
this 2d Java
so it doesn't require that I you know
sign any code or run anything that uses
3d acceleration it runs on a lot of
different systems here's another example
it just illustrates how plotting works
there are lots of different primitives
such as spheres icosahedron tetrahedrons
etc you can just add them together and
you get a scene and you can give
properties like one of Omega an orange
icosahedron I'll add it to a red sphere
that's transparent etc so if I evaluate
that here's what I get I get the scene
that has has those objects in it so I
have my acosta Hedra and I have my
sphere one of the spheres is transparent
and so on and there's also some cool
things you can set things spinning like
this so we're going to leave a demo
running or your teaching or something
you can if you want to give your
audience a headache you can do cross
side view and then everybody no it's
because I've zoomed in so much so they
could so that the fonts look good
it's kind of clipping it partly but if I
yeah let me it gets confused if you zoom
in a massive amount that's that's
causing trouble alright
yeah I'm really I'm confusing it by
zooming so much I think just unfortunate
geez that does not look happy it's
really clipped
okay so pretty gonna finish up so I
better not waste too much time on this
alright I'm just going to move on here's
another example of so here's an example
oh great
I have seriously messed this up let me
just refresh
so here's an example of weird that is
really weird
mmm-hmm somehow by zooming in and out of
punch I've confused the Java applet
big-time or yeah that's not good
hmm all right well not so good well
here's here's another example so this is
just an indexed face set so it's just a
bunch of 50,000 triangles yes
second or third you have red red random
stuff yes where does he fit around and
come from and I thought how bad is it
because there are so many bad ones out
there ah good question
there is a this guy Karl witty I
mentioned earlier the engineer who works
at Newton Labs he he really likes random
numbers so he he did come up with a nice
unified framework for our random numbers
there's a single file where the random
seeds are set for the various subsystems
so you can do set random seed and then
the gap random number generated all the
other round number generators and Perrie
etc they all get set so there's one
point where you can set everything there
are some really good random number
generation in GNP the new multi
precision library there's some good ones
in Python in some of our libraries so
the answer is there's a there's probably
20 at least 20 different random number
generators
there's also numpy which is one of the
libraries included in Sage has about 100
or so different distributions that it
implements so that gives you lots of
different differently distributed random
numbers so the answer is there's some
good rounded numbers or some bad random
numbers they're documented and you and
you have to look so the answer to your
question is there's all over the place
there's there's a lot of stuff but at
least there is a good framework for
setting the the seed for the random
number generator and figuring out what's
getting used I'll just go through this
example very quick so I'm running out of
time here's an example of an email that
appeared on sage support this Saturday
so it's a real world example of a some
sort of number theory calculation I
haven't thought about what he's actually
doing very much but he's iterating over
lots of values and computing the number
of numbers with some property okay so
it's a sort of thing that you could you
could it doesn't use too much just
iterating over ranges of numbers and
checking things like is something too
square and so on but the way he had
written it was creating a list of a
billion entries
in memory all at once which on his puny
computer would run out of RAM so there's
a way to just make a one letter change
to the function or well actually change
the notation slightly and instead of
creating the entire list at once it just
it makes a lazy list and that makes it
so his code would run so I started at
running and I told him this will work
instead in sage support in the mailing
list and then I started it running and
on his example he wanted to do this for
10 to the 9th and I kind of got bored
because it was sitting there for a long
time so I decided to change it to
cycling code which means that I put
percents light on at the top I
explicitly import some C library
function and then I declare some data
types I say everywhere T is going to be
a long long and instead of using sages
squared I'm going to use the C library
square root and Y is also going to be a
long long so I declare some data types
and then I hit shift enter so I'll do
that right here and then I tried I tried
this function on a couple of inputs and
for example for 10 to the 6th it turns
out that it's 238 times faster than the
uncompelled version so this is real
world code this is an actual user on
Saturday and we got that big of a
speed-up by using scythe on but you
clearing some data types then compiling
it so if you look at you click here it
shows you the code I just compiled but
it turns various parts of the code in to
see for example that code right here
gets turned into this C code and this if
check gets turned into that C code in
fact it's almost four things that just
involves C variables and C operations
it's a one-to-one translation it
literally just gets identically
translated into C so if the variables
get funny prefixed off you sick ate them
and that runs exactly the same speed as
C so it generates a C file some things
that are more complicated like a penny
to a Python list that you know as a
couple of lines of Python API code so it
generates this big file that can be
compiled using see it then compiles it
using a C compiler to make a shared
object library and then it links that in
every one time so that's what happens
behind the scenes
and it happens all when you hit shift
enter there's also a % 4chan you can
paste Fortran code into here no we'll do
something similar but with Fortran code
there's a couple of other things like
that and for 10 to the 9th his example
took 25 seconds I was able to rewrite it
in Saipan and run it in a lot less time
than it would have taken to it just wait
for the Python version to finish and
it's not contrived this happened it's a
real-world example okay so I thought by
the way it's a standalone project that
you can get if you use Python in any way
at all you can you can use scythe on
it's a completely separate thing from
sage and a lot of the development of
scythe on goes on at University of
Washington also but it's still a
separate project okay so for the very
end it's going to show you some examples
of number three here's making an
elliptic curve and plotting it over a
finite field which of course is just
random looking but it's fun to do that
just because you're not supposed to so
there you are here's an example of
computing the boolean group structure of
the elliptic curve over finite field so
given any elliptic curve over any finite
field tage has an algorithm that will do
this it's just using baby steps ient
step basically I'm John croman it
implemented that here's an example of
making an elliptic curve over a 60 digit
prime field and computing well
displaying it and then computing the
number of points on it which takes about
five seconds and this uses Perry it's a
third party out onto Perry called se a
GP here's an example of computing a
basis for a space of wait three modular
forms of level 12 see right there so
there's a bunch of all kinds of
different number three ability to
elliptic curves and so on but we do need
to improve a lot we'll be hyper elliptic
curves hyperelliptic curves on stage
have very little functionality there's a
little tiny bit we do have one thing we
can count the note we can compute the
matrix of Frobenius acting on the octina
on the elliptic curve very efficiently
and better than a lot of other system
well anything else but a lot of basic
operations with hyperelliptic curves are
not in sage which needs to be there for
crypto applications okay so that ends my
talk and I'm certainly out of time
are there any quick questions
that you have an artist ah yes so sage
is very good at that there are two
libraries called numpy and sai pi which
are mainly funded by and organized by
this company and thought in texas let me
just show you their website very quickly
and they're included in Sage so their
goal is to provide an alternative to
MATLAB based on Python they're
commercial but they're everything they
do is everything they release is BSD
licensed and we include their code in
Sage that gives us a quite a lot of
numerical computing functionality so I
mean you know they do it they do that
they do these numpy and they do a lot of
projects and the stuff they do is very
very good just to show you just a quick
example you can do well you can do
things that look like you're using sage
but behind the scenes that we'll use
like that makes a random matrix with
that makes a random 500 by yeah that's
not so useful oh that's a random 500 by
500 matrix with double precision entries
and let's say I want to do something
like compute all the eigenvalues
hopefully this works
so that takes under a second and behind
the scenes this is using numpy which has
stuff that's built on top of law pack
and blas and so on Sage incorporates
atlas so anytime you get sage' has a
optimized build of alice in it so that
gives us numerical linear algebra
there's a ton of numerical linear
algebra though if you do import well
let's just say there's a lot there's
also a lot of numerical optimization etc
so that's all part of this site by
library in port side PI for example you
import scipy I special that'll show you
a bunch of new miracle special fun
Asians much of which wraps Fortran
libraries the same Fortran libraries
that MATLAB is wrapping so you can see
there's a ridiculous and pages and pages
with special functions that are inside
PI or let's do side PI dot optimize and
for it
so I played optimize and then sify.com
eyes oops and then you see that there's
a lot of implementations of things in it
they're not just like you know some
cheesy implementation like F solve you
know it has its pretty sort of big thing
as you can see there's a ton of
different options and I think this is
presumably this is wrapping some
existing Fortran library but I think the
government sponsored the development of
a lot of of public domain Fortran code
over the years and that's incorporated
into sage Vyas I PI yes there's an
interactive debugger that you can only
use from the sage command-line so if I
start up sage over there then there's so
let's see ipython there's this project
ipython that makes a very nice
interactive command-line which saves
uses and it has integrated into it a
nice interactive debugger so if I if I I
don't know I'm sure what to do if you do
if you type percent p DB and then then
do something that leads to an error it
will give you a trace back and it'll
dump you to the point where the error
occurred and then you can start changing
variables so maybe maybe I'll try to
make a singular elliptic curve so
that'll obviously cause some sort of
error to occur and it dumps me to this
point in the code says line 147 of L
generic where it said the invariants
don't define a single don't define
define a singular curve so I can
actually print them it's not like I'm
running and I'm in that scope I can type
L and see the kind of code that's around
it I can see that it computed self dot
discriminant
can call that if I want I could like it
literally I think changed the variables
I'm not sure if this will work
yeah and now the discriminant oh because
it's cashed probably but you can you can
literally inspect variables locally and
step through and and see what happens so
now it's a pretty nice debugger for an
interpreter and this is often very
useful there's also a profiler you can
do percent P run and see you know maybe
you're annoyed that creating elliptic
curves seems to take too long so it'll
tell you what functions get called what
takes the most time how many times each
function is called etc so there's that
there are some IDs for developing Python
code like there's wing IDE which is a
commercial Windows IDE there's course
eclipse
so here's wing Python IDE and since you
know sage really in a sense sage is just
a Python library so any any tools out
there for working with Python you can
use with sage so well I should have
given me a screen shot but you can kind
of see there that there's some ID here
there's a number of different IDs those
also have debugging tools in them but a
lot of sage developers maybe we're
old-school OE basically is this command
line and print statements and stuff you
know but there's definitely well I
thought I'd talk on the weekend by a guy
from Simon he said that they're putting
a lot of effort into improving the the
tools for doing basically IDs for Python
development because they think that will
make Python a more desirable platform
for a lot of developers because right
now it's good but it could definitely be
better I mean you don't have something
like Visual Studio or something okay any
other questions cuz I'm definitely over
time I don't you to lunch
thank you